m
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
l'audition d'eric dupond-moretti
le garde des sceaux qui s'exprime cet
après-midi devant les sénateurs de la
commission des lois
ces sénateurs qui ont demandé son
audition dès sa nomination
les sénateurs socialistes notamment
veulent des éclaircissements sur de
nombreux sujets comme la réforme du
parquet la question de la justice des
mineurs ou encore l'expérimentation des
cours criminelles et les moyens
budgétaires qui vont être alloués à la
justice
notez que le nouveau garde des sceaux a
déjà été auditionné il a été auditionné
avant-hier par la commission des lois de
l'assemblée
il est passé sous le feu roulant des
questions des députés lors d'une
audition qui a duré trois heures et lors
de cette audition est bien eric dupond
moretti a promis de mener à terme la
réforme constitutionnelle concernant la
nomination des magistrats du parquet et
qui permettrait plus d'indépendance pour
le parquet concernant la question de la
justice des mineurs eric dupond moretti
a aussi annoncé vouloir défendre la
réforme qui a été décidé par nicole
belloubet 1 l'ex garde des sceaux
il a notamment promis lors de cette
audition une augmentation aussi
significative du budget de la justice
mais sans donner pour l'instant de
chiffrage précis il a en revanche
annoncé une enveloppe de 8 millions
d'euros permettant l'arrivée de 1000
vacataires pour régler le stock
d'affaires accumulé et cela pendant le
confinement
concernant est bien la question de la
justice des mineurs
notez que cette justice repose sur une
ordonnance qui viennent de 70 ans qui
datent de 1945
une réforme qui prévoit notamment un
seuil d'irresponsabilité pénale fixé à
13 ans et qui instaure une nouvelle
procédure pénale dans le but de réduire
les délais de jugement c'est un sujet
qui crispe très fortement les syndicats
vous le voyez eh bien on voit déjà du
monde qui est arrivé dans cette salle
clemenceau salle où va se dérouler cette
audition une audition qui devrait durer
une heure et demi ici au sénat l'avait
dur et je vous le disais trois heures à
l'assemblée nationale de nombreux
journalistes sont présents pour cette
audition très attendue du garde des
sceaux devant la commission des lois
commission qui est présidé par le
sénateur les républicains philippe bas
philippe bas que vous voyez ici masqué
conformément et bien à ce qui dicte les
règles depuis lundi il faut être masquée
dans les lieux publics clos et tout de
suite nous allons pouvoir donc écouter
cette audition c'est donc philippe pas
qui est en train d'introduire cette
mission d'eric dupond british comment
vous allez pouvoir mettre l'expérience
que vous avez acquises au service de la
défense des justiciables au service du
redressement du service public de la
justice
nous ne pouvons évidemment nous
satisfaire de porter le débat sur le
terrain des principes généraux ni de
considérer que les modalités de
nomination des procureurs leur
indépendance le rôle du garde des sceaux
vis-à-vis des parquets sont les
principales d'urgence de l'actualité
judiciaire
même s'il s'agit de questions
importantes pour nous ce qui est
essentiel c'est de vérifier comment vous
pourrez par votre action obtenir une
accélération de la justice une
simplification de celle ci pour qu'elle
soit mieux comprise de nos concitoyens
un rapprochement plus de proximité à
l'égard des justiciables et sur le plan
pénal
nous attachons de l'importance à la
remise à niveau de notre appareil
pénitentiaire il était l'une des
urgences que vous est-ce que vous avez
souligné lors de votre prise de fonction
et aussi comment faire en sorte que à la
première infraction des sanctions
appropriées et certaines soient mises en
oeuvre
nous attachons également de l'importance
à la prévention de la récidive qui est
un mal français particulièrement
important
et nous nous interrogeons finalement sur
les moyens que vous serez en possibilité
de mobiliser pour aller plus loin que la
loi de programmation de la justice que
nous avons refusé de voter en raison de
l'insuffisance des crédits qu'elles
comportent par rapport aux évaluations
que nous avions fait dans notre rapport
d'avril 2010 7 5 ans pour sauver la
justice
nous travaillons en effet depuis
longtemps sur ces questions nous avons
conscience de la nécessité d'un effort
très important de redressement du
service public de la justice à inscrire
dans la durée au delà des échéances
électorales d alternance et des clivages
politiques
nous avons une audition qui sera courte
monsieur le garde des sceaux puisqu'elle
doit impérativement se terminer aux
alentours de 14h50
nous devons donc accepter les uns et les
autres une forte discipline
je vous demanderais vous même monsieur
le garde des sceaux de l'appliquer en ne
dépassant pas dix minutes de propos
introductif mais mes chers collègues au
moment où vous aurez à poser vos
questions il faut que vous vous
appliquiez la règle des deux minutes que
nous nous appliquons en séance notamment
pour les questions d'actualité car sinon
ce sera une immense frustration pour le
ministre qui ne pourra pas répondre à
toutes les questions que vous souhaitez
lui poser et auxquelles il a
naturellement à l'avance à coeur de
pouvoir répondre
donc je ne serai pas plus long dans mon
propre propos introductif pour cette
première rencontre entre vous et nous je
dois vous signaler que cette audition a
été ouverte aux sénateurs de toutes les
commissions et pas seulement aux
sénateurs de la commission des lois mais
je serai contraint de donner pour les
questions la priorité au monde
de la commission même si j'espère que
nous pourrons aussi avoir des questions
d'autres collègues et qui sont
aujourd'hui présents et leur présence
montre à quel point le sénat attachent
de l'importance à cette modernisation du
service public de la justice vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mesdames et messieurs les commissaires
au loin je suis heureux de l'occasion
qui m'est aujourd'hui offerte quelques
jours après ma prise de fonction en
qualité de garde des sceaux de pouvoir
vous présenter l'action que j'entends
mener à la tête du ministère de la
justice
je suis heureux aussi de pouvoir évoquer
avec vous les chantiers que je souhaite
engager sans tarder pour rapprocher la
justice des citoyens et améliorer son
fonctionnement
vous me permettrez donc de remercier
très chaleureusement le président
philippin pour son aimable invitation
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
préambule vous le savez peut-être une
personne détenus du centre pénitentiaire
de roanne retenaient jusqu'à il y à
quelques minutes sa compagne à l'issue
d'un parloir
l'équipe régionale d'intervention et de
sécurité de lyon s'est rendu sur le site
la prise d'otage semble terminée si tant
est qu'on puisse à cet instant la
qualifier de la sorte et mes services
vont évidemment me tenir rigoureusement
informés de la suite des événements
encore que à cet instant tout danger
semble être écartée mais ce président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
vous savez comme moi que le temps est
tout à la fois précieux et compter dans
la présente mandature
pourtant des inflexions majeures peuvent
d'ores et déjà être apporté un système
judiciaire
vous pourriez convenir tristement avec
moi qu'il souffre aujourd'hui d'une
véritable défiance de la part de nos
concitoyens
cette situation à l'évidence n'est pas
satisfaisante et je veux précisément
m'employer à la corriger
changer le regard des français sur leur
justice les réconcilie avec elle ce sont
mes espérances au moment où j'assume la
responsabilité que m'a confié monsieur
président de la république et monsieur
le premier ministre
ce combat pour la restauration du lien
de confiance entre les citoyens et la
justice n'est pas seulement celui du
ministre et de son administration
celui des magistrats des greffiers des
agents qui tous je le jure je le mesure
chaque jour davantage son remarquable
d'engagement de compétences de
dévouement pour le service public de la
justice
c'est le combat du gouvernement tout
entier qui par la voix du premier
ministre a fait vous le savez de la
réforme de la justice une priorité ce
combat il nécessite le soutien de la
représentation nationale et tout
particulièrement celui du sénat et des
membres de votre commission des lois qui
ont consacré d'importants travaux au
projet ambitieux et partager de
redressement de la justice pour
reprendre l'intitulé de votre rapport
d'information de 2017
sur la base de ce constat partagé la
nécessaire est très urgent redressement
de la justice
de très importants son chantier de
modernisation comme le plan de
transformation numérique ont été lancées
par ma prédécesseure madame nicole
belloubet et je souhaite saluer devant
vous son engagement ses compétences et
son action au cours des trois années
passées il m'appartient désormais de
faire aboutir plusieurs des importantes
réformes lancées sous son ministère
comme la loi sur la bioéthique le
parquet européen ou encore la réforme
tant attendue de l' ordonnance de 1945
j'ai déjà eu la grande satisfaction hier
devant la haute assemblée
depoorter une loi destinée à renforcer
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
c'est pour moi un honneur et un motif de
grande satisfaction que d'avoir pu
achever les travaux auxquels a participé
ma prédécesseure et auquel était associé
bien sûr madame morano ministre de
l'égalité hommes femmes sur ce sujet de
première importance
toutes les actions seront engagées pour
donner leur plus grande portée aux
conclusions du grenelle contre les
violences conjugales
je veut en particulier que les femmes
victimes soit entendu qu'elle reçoive un
meilleur accueil dans les commissariats
et les gendarmeries qu'elle soit prise
en charge par le milieu hospitalier au
plus près de leur domicile
je souhaite créer 7 à cette fin des
unités de proximité dans les hôpitaux et
j'ai obtenu l'assurance de leur
financement je veux aussi qu'une réponse
soit apportée à la personne qu'ils
suspectaient de violences conjugales ne
peut pas être déféré
car la procédure n'est peut-être pas
terminée je souhaite qu'elle rencontre
un magistrat du parquet qui la met en
garde contre ce type d'agissement afin
qu'il y est un rappel de la loi
indépendamment des poursuites engagées
ou non plus tardivement
au titre de ma feuille de route pour les
presque 600 jours à venir il me revient
pour répondre à l'objectif de justice de
proximité est fixé par le premier
ministre d'ouvrir de nouveaux chantiers
et d'apporter surtout des améliorations
concrètes au fonctionnement des
juridictions le travail vous le savez ne
ne manquent pas pour le ministre de la
justice mais aussi pour le parlement
dans différentes missions de législateur
mais aussi de contrôleurs et d'aiguillon
du pouvoir exécutif et je ne demande
qu'à travailler étroitement et en
confiance avec vous vous savez ma
connaissance de la justice n'est pas
technocratique
je n'ai pas encore tout appris en dépit
de la très grande qualité de mes
enseignants ma connaissance de la
justice elle est charnelle et nourri par
une expérience de plus de 30 ans dans
presque tous les tribunaux de france
elle est humaine elle est intime c'est
pour cela que le dénuement de notre
justice son décrochage par rapport au
système judiciaire des autres pays
européens
la dégradation de son image dans
l'opinion publique les condamnations
multiples de la france par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à
l'occasion de procès inéquitables me
sont devenues insupportables
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai décidé de
m'engager au côté du président de la
république pour améliorer la justice de
notre pays et agir au soutien des femmes
et des hommes qui travaillent dans les
juridictions comme dans les services et
établissements de la protection
judiciaire
ne les oublions pas surtout pas et de
l'administration pénitentiaire ne les
oublions pas surtout pas la priorité de
mon action porte donc je voulais indiqué
sur la mise en place d'une justice de
proximité un petit point de sémantique
d'abord tant il est vrai que mal nommer
les choses a écrit camus s'est aggravé
les malheurs du monde
le premier ministre a évoqué la
nécessité évidente d'avoir des juges de
proximité
beaucoup se sont étonnés il n'a jamais
été question de rétablir ce qui a été
supprimée en 2010 7 mai
à droit constant avec les plaines
possibilité offerte par la loi de
programmation et de réforme de la
justice de faire en sorte que la justice
soit rendue au plus près de nos
concitoyens telle est notre objectif
et il peut être atteint par la tenue
d'audiences foraines en plus grand
nombre et surtout par l'utilisation
effective des dispositions du nouvel
article l de sang 18-8 du code de
l'organisation judiciaire
cette disposition permet en effet aux
chefs de cour d'attribuer les
compétences matériel supplémentaire à
une chambre de proximité d'un tribunal
judiciaire
dans l'ensemble des matières civiles et
pénales relevant de la compétence du
tribunal judiciaire
vous êtes la haute assemblée des
territoires et il me faut vous préciser
que ces attributions de compétences aux
chambres de proximité ne sont pas prises
unilatéralement et depuis paris mais au
terme d'une réflexion et d'une
concertation conduites localement
après consultation du conseil de
juridiction et ce conseil comprend
notamment le maire de la commune siège
du tribunal judiciaire
le président du conseil départemental et
le bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats du
ressort
les élus doivent être écoutés et
entendus car ils connaissent les
préoccupations locales et je veux
travailler aussi permettez-moi
d'insister sûr ce point au rapprochement
des élus et de la justice s'agissant des
attributions de compétences il me paraît
souhaitable
sous réserve d appréciation locale que
les juges aux affaires familiales et les
juges des enfants se déplacent dans les
territoires ou encore que les petits
délits et les incivilités soient
rapidement jugés en proximité qu'un
effort soit fait également pour les
victimes je suis très sensible à
l'accueil qui leur est réservé et elles
doivent être entendus lorsque la gravité
des faits justifient qu'une attention
toute particulière leur soit porté la
réalisation de cet objectif nécessite
des renforts en personnel et je sais par
le retour à la trajectoire de la loi de
programmation et des améliorations
ciblées
que ces objectifs nous pourrons les
atteindre je sais le premier ministre
attentif aux besoins de la justice et je
vais mettre tout mon poids ton écrire
toutes mes forces madame la directrice
de cabinet dans la balance pour obtenir
ces moyens nécessaires nous allons sans
doute avoir l'occasion d'en reparler et
je sais votre commission et votre autre
assemblée très vigilante à ce sujet
comme en ont témoigné sur le projet de
loi de finances pour 2020 les avis de la
sénatrice josiane cost et des sénateurs
yves détraigne et à la marque
je souhaite également ce sont là des
réformes qui ne coûte rien généraliser
sur l'ensemble du territoire les bonnes
pratiques qui émane des agents ces
bonnes pratiques mises au point et
expérimenté dans les territoires doivent
pouvoir bénéficier à tous il s'agit là
de bon sens avec une amélioration
concrète pour le justiciable et le
travail des juridictions
à titre d'exemple un parmi tant d'autres
la crise sanitaire a conduites à
améliorer localement l'organisation des
convocations des justiciables
avec des horaires séquencé et adapté ça
peut paraître peu de choses
c'est primordial en réalité pour le
justiciable et ses 7 à son égard une
marque de respect de l'institution
il est aussi dans les intentions outre
l'achèvement déjà mentionné des travaux
initiés par ma prédécesseure de
poursuivre et de lancer un certain
nombre de chantiers avec le même
objectif d'amélioration de la justice et
le traitement qu'on crée des difficultés
je souhaite d'abord l'aboutissement de
la réforme de l'article 65 de la
constitution
cette réforme permettra de soumettre les
nominations des magistrats du parquet à
l'avis conforme du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature et il donnera au csm
pouvoir de décision sur la discipline
des magistrats du parquet à l'identique
de ceux du ciel
un projet de loi constitutionnelle a
déjà été adopté dans les mêmes termes
par l'assemblée nationale et sénat en
2016 pour mener cette réforme à son
terme il est nécessaire qu'elle soit
adoptée soit par référendum soit par le
congrès cette décision appartient
évidemment à monsieur président de la
république je veux ensuite faire aboutir
une réflexion nourrie par l'expérience
et que je porte depuis longtemps
relatives à l' enquête préliminaire et à
la détention provisoire
l'enquète préliminaire dure trop souvent
trop longtemps elle n'est plus
préliminaire elle devient éternel sans
le contradictoire consubstantielle à
l'idée même de justice s'agissant de la
détention provisoire les nécessaires
dans certains cas mais doit rester la
loi le dit déjà exceptionnel d'autres
moyens existent
je demanderai au parquet de prendre des
réquisitions ce sens
je souhaite également travailler sur la
présomption d'innocence ministre par an
révèle absolument pas vous interromps
mais je le fais quand même je crois si
je vous en avais la possibilité qu'il
faudrait contractée la semaine et les
introductions parce que mes collègues ne
vont pas pouvoir pour poser les
questions qu'ils ont envie de vous poser
mais monsieur le président vous murray
inviterait je reviendrai avec un immense
plaisir pour m'expliquer c'est la
première fois que je prends complètement
la parole au sénat oui j'ai eu un
discours qui était un peu préparé que
nous avons travaillé vous me demander de
le chanter d'une certaine façon
j'accepte l'aube sûrs de ce découpage
mais c'est un peu compliqué tout de même
je voudrais expliquer un certain nombre
de choses je répondrai aux questions à
l'aise ici le temps nous manque je je je
je reviendrai bien volontiers mais bien
sûr de vous ou je m'arrête immédiatement
et est jalouse accusé au jeu des
questions si vous de ce que vous
préférez les deux places et je préfère
permis d'aller au bout de votre propos
mais je vous ce jeu vous connaît de
grandes capacités oratoires
je suis persuadé que vous pouvez aller
jusqu'au terme
sans forcément lire l'ensemble du propos
mais c'est à vous de le décider
je veux également voit le faire en
chapitres en un peu les choses j'ai
également travaillé sur la présomption
d'innocence
le secret de l'enquète dans la
concertation avec les différents acteurs
concernés notamment les journalistes
la question des mineurs et de la justice
est pour moi un sujet de préoccupation
vous aurez prochainement connaître à ce
sujet la réforme de l'ordonnancé de 45
mes convictions sont claires je vous les
livre le plus simplement possible
le prix le plus brillé vraiment possible
monsieur président je souhaite que les
mineurs soient jugés dans les meilleurs
délais et non au delà de leur majorité
comme ça arrive parfois ça n'a aucun
sens il ya des gamins qui connaît qui
commettent des faits à 16 ans ils sont
jugés à 22 ils sont mariés ils ont
changé de vie il ya un certain nombre de
réformes à faire je pense que vous
m'interrogez là dessus et j'aurai le
loisir d'expliciter ma pensée est mon
point de vue la condition pénitentiaire
dans tous ses aspects est aussi un des
points forts de mon action je veux
d'abord rendre hommage au personnel de
l'administration pénitentiaire bien sûr
on est à un taux historiquement bas de
détenus je souhaiterais dans la mesure
du possible qu'on le maintienne
je vais très très vite je sors même de
mon discours pour vous dire que j'ai été
le témoin passif mais extrêmement
attentif d'une conversation entre deux
jeunes détenus et le personnel
pénitentiaire il disait exactement la
même chose
les uns disaient nous avons amélioré
notre condition et les autres disent eh
ben nous quand la condition des détenus
est améliorée on peut travailler on peut
faire de la pédagogie et donc de la
réinsertion en matière pénale
la fréquentation des cours d'assises et
des établissements pénitentiaires ont
occupé vous le savez une grande partie
de ma vie d'avocat je vais laisser les
expérimentations en cours mais je ne
veux pas que la cour d'assises meurs je
vais très très vite je prends un mot
partage monsieur le président pour vous
être pour vous être agréable
la justice administrative a engagé
devant tant de courses choisies devront
proposer de prendre votre temps
la justice a admis le race ni
administratives aussi méritent un
certain nombre de deux
deux modifications nous en parlerons si
si vous le voulez bien
et enfin la justice européenne et
notamment le
le parquet européen voilà le programme
que je viens d'esquisser en le
comprimant un peu et dont je vous en
ferai entretiendrez régulièrement dans
les mois à venir est un programme
ambitieux je sais pouvoir compter sur
votre haute assemblée pour bénéficier à
la fois de votre soutien
mais aussi de vos éclairages je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur le ministre
vous allez voir vous allez pouvoir
entrer dans le détail
en répondant aux questions de mes
collègues j'observe que cette affaire de
justice de proximité
on avait sans doute mal compris le
premier ministre et qu'en réalité c'est
plutôt la proximité de la justice qui
est votre objectif que la justice de
proximité au sens où l'entend depuis
2003 et l'institution des juges de
proximité qui ont depuis lors disparu
mais cette clarification et être utile
je voudrais vous dire puisque vous avez
parlé du retour à la trajectoire de la
loi de programmation pour la justice que
c'était expression m'a rendu perplexe
parce que moi j'avais compris même si je
sais et vous en faites ici l'aveu que la
trajectoire n'est pas suivie puisque on
est seulement pour l'année 2010 19 à peu
près la moitié de la hausse prévue dans
la loi de programmation judiciaire mais
j'avais compris que le président de la
république et le premier ministre vous
avez donné des assurances pour non
seulement rétablir l'application d'une
loi qui n'a pas été correctement
appliquée mais aussi augmenter les
moyens de la justice et nous avons
conscience lorsque je vous dis cela que
les moyens qui sont nécessaires ne vont
pas sans réformes car on ne peut pas
demander la hausse des moyens de la
justice pour rendre la justice à
l'identique et nous sommes évidemment
très soucieux de vous entendre sur les
chiffres de l'augmentation des moyens de
la justice que vous voulez mettre en
oeuvre et sur les
les éléments de réforme pour la
simplification l'accélération de la
justice et comme vous l'avez mentionné
vous même le rapprochement de la justice
à l'égard des citoyens
je trouve l'idée de développer ce qui
existe déjà dans notre droit à savoir ce
qu'on appelle la justice foraine dans
des termes incompréhensible pour le
public et qui revient à permettre aux
greffiers et aux magistrats de se
déplacer au plus près des justiciables
pour rendre une justice de proximité je
trouve que cette idée est une bonne idée
mais je voudrais savoir comment vous
entendez la mettre en oeuvre dont je
vous redonne la parole pour que vous
puissiez nous apporter à ce stade les
précisions que vous êtes en mesure de
nous apporter
écoutez monsieur le président je vais
vous être agréable et je vais être très
rapide car vous le savez les arbitrages
seront prochainement rendus donc pour
les chiffres il faudrait que vous me
rées invitiez et je le détaillerai très
volontiers mon premier objectif c'est de
recoller à la trajectoire de la lpj
disposer de moyens supplémentaires pour
mettre en oeuvre la justice de proximité
par la création supplémentaire par
exemple de juristes assistants et par un
soutien aux personnels de greffe
aujourd'hui en difficulté remettre à
niveau revaloriser certaines filières
comme la filière socio-éducative les
grèves tout en étant attentif à la
situation des autres personnels du
ministère voilà ce que rapidement je
peux vous dire pour les chiffres que
vous le savez il faut attendre un peu
que les hommes que les arbitrages soient
soit rendue et vous aurez toutes les
précisions lorsque je les aurai moi même
je vous remercie et j'espère que ça ne
résoudrait de bons arbitres aoûtienne
ministre quand c'est nécessaire
alors je vais donner la parole
maintenant à mes collègues
si vous voulez bien nous prendrons les
questions par groupe de trois je donne
la parole d'abord à madame troendlé
merci monsieur le président messieurs
ministre dans son discours de politique
générale devant l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre a indiqué vouloir
promouvoir la justice de la vie
quotidienne
considérant et je le cite dans beaucoup
de territoires la petite délinquance les
petites incivilités le tag l'insultent
le petit trafic les troubles à ce que le
code communal appelle la tranquillité
publique se sont développées au point de
gâcher la vie des gens ils se sont
développés car faute de réponse
judiciaire
une forme d'impunité s'est installée
pourtant monsieur le ministre depuis les
années 1920 années 90 la justice s'est
efforcé d'apporter une réponse pénale à
la grande majorité des infractions votre
ministère indiquait qu'une réponse
pénale est apportée à 88% des auteurs
d'infractions dans 80% des cas la
réponse pénale consiste en des
poursuites devant une juridiction pour
le solde il s'agit de mesures
alternatives aux poursuites ou de
comparution pénale de composition pénale
excusez moi dans ce contexte pourriez
vous nous préciser quelles initiatives
supplémentaires
vous comptez prendre pour lutter encore
plus efficacement contre la petite
délinquance du quotidien et le problème
de fond monsieur ministre n'est-il pas
que beaucoup d'auteurs d'infractions ne
sont pas tout simplement identifier
madame de la gontrie merci président
monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez à plusieurs reprises
aujourd'hui comme hier d'ailleurs
souligné la nécessité de rétablir la
confiance entre les citoyens et la
justice
mais c'est sur ce point que je
souhaiterais vous interrogez vous avez
prêté serment en 1984 il est à 36 ans
vous avez je crois était avocat s'en
sent désemparé vous avez une au long de
votre carrière un grand nombre de
clients
certains sans doute plus connu que
d'autres mais dans la période récente
adelkhah derniera jérôme cahuzac théo
luhaka julian assange est donc je pense
que comme la conférence nationale des
procureurs de la république ne demande
d'ailleurs il faudrait que vous puissiez
clarifier les conditions de la remontée
d'informations dans les affaires
individuelles la nature de votre
relation avec le barreau vous êtes-vous
fait au m avez vous démissionné
je vous ai entendu l'autre jour répondre
à laurent delahousse que vous ne saviez
pas et ce n'est pas moi qui vous en
ferai leurs proches
si vous reprendriez ou non la robe à la
fin de cette mission de ministre quelle
organisation
avez vous mis en place au sein des
ministères pour interdire toute remontée
d'informations avez vous comme gérald
darmanin adressé une lettre de déport
afin que les affaires qui vous ont
concerné ne vous remontent pas avez-vous
précisément dans la circonstance de la
procédure visant votre collègue de
gouvernement gérald darmanin mis en
place un dispositif spécifique sur
l'ensemble de ces questions êtes vous
prêt à la transparence totale de manière
à ce que la confiance soit totale dans
votre rôle au sein de ce ministère
merci cher collègue monsieur pierre yves
collombat
majorité sa maison
la chambre représentant les territoires
c'est la question de la responsabilité
pénale des mères et de leurs délégués si
la longue file de leur responsabilité
universelle n'a rien à voir avec celle
du citoyen lambda ou même d'un chef
d'entreprise voire d'un médecin ou d'un
avocat
il en va différemment de leurs
responsabilités pénales
au mieux elle est la même souvent elle
est plus lourde au motif que l'intéressé
est investie d'un mandat électif public
d'un pouvoir général de police ou
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
nous sommes nombreux au sénat a
considéré que la réduction de ce
déséquilibre appelle la révision du code
pénal sur trois points préciser les
notions de prise illégale d'intérêt et
de délit de favoritisme ce que le sénat
a fait à l'unanimité à l'unanimité à
l'unanimité par deux fois ici mais qui a
disparu dans le trou noir de la navette
précisé enfin l'article l 122 4 du code
pénal en donnant force de loi à l'arrêt
de la cour d'appel de douai du 10
octobre 2012
relaxant le baird coulson précédemment
condamné pour avoir donné une gifle à un
adolescent provocateur un dossier que
vous connaissez bien monsieur le garde
des sceaux pensez vous possible de faire
évoluer les choses simplement en
demandant l'inscription à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée générale de
l'assemblée nationale par dont deux des
deux textes votés par le sénat
mon gré à gré du temps et vous pouvez
régler un problème qui traîne depuis des
années et qu'on se refuse à regarder en
face merci chers collègues je vais
continuer à vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre vous prie de m'en
excuser parce que j'ai un afflux de
demandes de deux collègues qui veulent
vous poser des questions je voudrais
autant que possible réussir à ce que
chacun puisse poser sa question monsieur
waterblez je vais faire vite merci
d'être présents monsieur le ministre
vous êtes prêt du secret d'instruction
et moi j'aurais aimé votre sentiment en
tant qu'avocat sur secret de
l'instruction
on a bien sûr la personne entendue les
personnes qui auditionne
le juge l'avocat et la presse est bien
souvent la presse est d'informer à la
minute près de l'instruction quelquefois
même avant le rendu est la personne qui
a entendu se retrouve avec quelquefois
des gros titres
toujours avec j'irai quelques guillemets
mais bien souvent condamné moralement
finalité et le temps que ça dure sept
personnes pèse porte ce poids là ça peut
durer un an deux ans est bien souvent
une certaine presse revient sur ces
sujets même si cette personne n'a pas
été condamné juridiquement et ça c'est
un point où dans votre fonction
aujourd'hui il faudrait c'est un serpent
de mer pourrait résoudre parce que c'est
pas possible de continuer comme ça à
quelqu'un qui est entendue et forcément
un petit peu moralement la fin par la
presse mis en examen
monsieur le président sur wii merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez parlé de
l'indépendance du parquet et de la
réforme du csm
je voulais vous demander car vous avez
sans doute pris des engagements lors de
l'acceptation de ce poste si vous pouvez
vous engager à ce que d'ici la fin de ce
mandat soit véritablement déposer une
loi constitutionnelle elle a déjà été
voté par les deux assemblées de telle
manière qu'elles puissent venir au
congrès pour être rapidement voté mais
je précise qu'il ne s'agirait pas en
l'occurrence d'une loi portant une
immense réformes constitutionnelles
concernant notamment le nombre de
députés de sénateurs le modèle et cetera
car dans ce cas on va naufragés la
réforme si elle ne porte que là dessus
il y a de fortes chances pour qu'elle
existe et je voulais savoir ce que vous
comptez faire à cet égard deuxièmement
vous avez dit que vous alliez vous
battre comme un forcené ce qui n'est pas
rien pour que la cour d'assises ne meurt
pas il ne vous a pas échappé que
l'expérimentation pour sept tribunaux
criminels
n'allez peut-être pas dans le sens
ce combat surtout monsieur le ministre
quand elle a été quand elle a été étendu
à trente et un départements d'après le
projet de loi dit cette suite à la cmp
allez vous revenir sur l'exprimer il
suffit d'un article de loi monsieur le
ministre vous le savez sur cette
expérimentation afin de défendre bec et
ongles comme vous l'avez dit là le jury
populaire et enfin puisque vous êtes
très attaché à la réforme de la justice
des mineurs
allez vous renoncer à la faire par voie
d'ordonnancé mais plutôt nous présenter
un projet de loi ce qui permettra un
véritable débat parlementaire sur le
sujet je vous remercie
eh bien monsieur le ministre voilà une
première moisson de questions tout très
précise et intéressante je vous donne la
parole
sur les maisons alors par de mémoire il
ya un certain nombre de choses je
mesdames et messieurs mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs qui
étaient contenues dans mon discours
initial mais pour les raisons que vous
savez elle génère maintenant une
frustration des questions auxquelles je
vais tenter de répondre mais rapidement
monsieur le vouvoyer les questions vous
permettent de dire ce que vous avez à
dire bon d'abord première question qui
m'est posée par madame trois anglais
sénatrice un accord des mois d'abord que
quand les auteurs d'une infraction ne
sont pas identifiés niveau nîmois nous
n'y pouvons quelque chose au-delà du
taux de réponse
ce qui me paraît extrêmement important
c'est le délai de réponse je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure qu'un gamin comme est
défait à 16 ans et qu'ils soient
sanctionnés à 22 ça n'a strictement
aucun sens alors on choisira le vocable
le moment venu juge de proximité juge de
l'urgence je n'en sais rien mais ce que
je souhaite c'est que dès qu'une
infraction est commise et que des
naturellement que l'auteur est identifié
dans les heures qui suivent ils
reçoivent un message judiciaire je crois
en la pédagogie de la justice les
magistrats les avocats croient en la
pédagogie de la justice la justice ça
n'est pas fait que pour punir c'est pour
délivrer aussi un avertissement
c'est insupportable pour nos concitoyens
monsieur le premier ministre a évoqué sa
ville de prades
je connais la ville de coûts sort que
vous évoquez monsieur monsieur le
sénateur je suis originaire de ce
village
j'ai défendu le maire qui avait giflé un
gamin et que la cour d'appel de douai
heureusement a fini par relaxé il ya des
gamins qui commettent les petites
exactions les incivilités insupportable
qui cassent des pots de fleurs etc et
les gens ils sont exaspérés par ça ils
ont le sentiment et c'est un sentiment
c'est presque plus grave le sentiment
d'insécurité que l'insécurité parce que
le sentiment d'insécurité il permet le
fantasme et donc les gens sont exaspérés
il n'y a pas de réponse immédiate et ça
démoralise complètement les forces de
l'ordre qui disent nous on entend ça
tous les jours on les interpelle on fait
rien les juges sont laxistes tout le
monde s'en fiche céda je mette un terme
à ça je voudrais qu un gamin qui se
fasse forme en train de taguer le
lendemain ils puissent repeindre un mur
de commissariats et qui en a bien besoin
voilà ce que je souhaite mettre en place
je pense que ça parle aux français qu'
au-delà des clivages politiciens qui
peuvent exister on peut être tous
d'accord sur des mesures de cette nature
monsieur le ministre
ça existe déjà ça existe mais ça existe
mais ça fonctionne le malade donc il
faut il faut le faire fonctionner c'est
pas une réforme législative mais je n'ai
pas parlé de jets pas parler de réformes
législatives
j'aurai peu de temps je veux aller vite
mon temps est compté mais ça ne sera pas
du temps perdu
il faut qu'on mette en oeuvre un certain
nombre de d'application de ce qui peut
exister de bonnes pratiques pour aller
vers l'essentiel
je vous donne d'autres exemples de ce
qu'est la justice pour moi la justice de
proximité j'ai dit valeur dans mon
discours les divorces les gens ils ont
rien fait de mal et se retrouve à 30,35
dans une même salle
ils n'ont rien fait ces gens là leur vie
est en train d'être déchiquetés
c'est extrêmement douloureux elle et les
américains qui font des sondages surtout
disent que c'est un des moments de vie
les plus difficiles à surmonter
on les parque dans une salle à 30,35 le
coc vide nous a permis de découvrir
qu'on pouvait faire autrement d'ailleurs
les avocats lé savent ils sont
intervenus à de nombreuses reprises pour
démasquer plus possible convoqué les uns
et les autres de façon séquencée et
c'est plus humain
bah voilà les petites mesures qui sont
toutes simples le divorce également qui
est rendu aujourd'hui c'est un jeu de
conclusion d'un avocat
le jeu de conclusion d'un autre avocat
les intéressés ne voit même plus le juge
est ce que vous pensez franchement que
c'est satisfaisant
et c'est des tas de mesures comme ça que
nous avons déjà collecté qui ne méritent
pas d'intervention légistatives
forcément mais qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre madame euh pardon de sionisme
traînerait voulait voulais juste
préciser sa question
allez-y c'est le plan dont aller s'il
vous plaît madame traîneau monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit on à vos propos
que je vous avais dit qu'il avait
beaucoup d'auteurs d'infractions qui ne
sont pas identifiés vous m'avez répondu
je n'y peux rien moi oui je n'y peux
rien vous non plus je pense que si vous
pourriez par les eaux à votre collègue
du ministère de l'intérieur ministre de
l'intérieur et lui demander de débloquer
plus de moyens pour les enquêteurs
allez monsieur ministre allez-y me
répondait à madame de la gontrie puis
les choses sont extrêmement claires
j'ai identifié les dossiers allez-y
monsieur le ministre vous seul avez la
parole pour l'instant alors je je je
suis au mit j'ai identifié avec mon
équipe
les dossiers qui sont problématiques ça
n'a pas été simple parfois parce que
j'ai plus défendre quelqu'un il ya 15
ans qui peut revenir vous savez sur le
devant de la scène
je suis très clair là dessus je ne
m'interdis aucune remontée d'information
sauf celles qui ont pu conserver mon
activité antérieure je vous dirai ce que
j'ai fait je m'interdis en revanche et
nous sommes dans les clous des textes de
donner quelques directives que ce soit à
qui que ce soit c'est très clair ceci
étant dit vous le savez comme moi c'est
le lieu là aussi de tous les fantasmes
et de toutes les interprétations et
personne ne sera jamais convaincu il ya
un grand principe de notre droit c'est
que la mauvaise foi ne se présume pas
alors s'agissant des affaires qui m'ont
concerné je n'aurais sur ces questions
là aucune remontée d'émanations peu
d'informations aucune strictement aucune
il ya une liste ya nos listes
mais le ministre a dans ce cadre ainsi
si vous trouvez une solution plus plus
adéquate à la situation
franchement je suis preneur parce que
nous avons réfléchi on n'a pas trouvé
d'autre solution que celle là il ya une
liste
ensuite j'aurai forcément une
déontologie et j'entends la respecter je
ne recevrait aucune information des
affaires qui ont pu me concerne et nous
ne pouvons pas avoir une exigence qui je
reviendrai finalement interdire un
amalgame de mai monsieur le ministre
en laissant de côté votre cas personnel
il ya une chose que j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi vouloir maintenir
les remontées d'informations jusqu au
garde des sceaux
tout en affirmant que le garde des
sceaux ne s'en servira jamais pour
donner des instructions au parquet il me
semble qu'il ya une sorte de
contradiction à quoi vont vous servir
ses remontées d'informations de manière
très précise si vous pouvez répondre à
cette question à quoi sert d'informer le
garde des sceaux s'il n'a pas le droit
d'intervenir
je ne plaide pas pour son droit
d'intervention mais je me dis qu'il ya
une zone opaque et qu'une clarification
pourrait peut-être être utile ou alors
vous allez nous donner une réponse très
simple pour nous dire c'est nécessaire
que le garde des sceaux soit informé
mais ça ne va pas sans le dire et sans
l'expliquer et 100 en débattre je crois
que les choses en réalité sont très
simples le garde des sceaux reçoit des
instructions et il est normal que le
garde des sceaux sache quelles sont les
affaires qui peuvent concerner l'état le
fonctionnement de l'état c'est une de
ses missions ensuite de l'aa communiqué
attendez pour quoi faire pour être
informé pourquoi mais pourquoi quand
vous organisez une commission denquête
vous le faites pour être en forme et sur
une situation vous voudriez en savoir
plus que moi pour faire la transparence
démocratique mais pardonnez moi je suis
aussi le chef de la politique pénale et
il me paraît tout à fait tout à fait
normal que le garde des sceaux souhaite
informer je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que
son au texte si vous souhaitez en
changer
vous avez une liberté d'intervention que
je ne vous contesterait pas mais en
l'état ce sont nos textes
moi j'entends recevoir les informations
de l'arast à les utiliser pour appeler
tel procureur ou pire encore tel juge du
siège
non je vous dis que non et là aussi ce
sont nos textes et je suis tenu de
respecter la loi c'est qu'elle est bien
fait
je pense que c'est celle là qui existe
pour le moment nous en discuterons
peut-être mais il n'y a aucune raison
que dans le cadre d'une commission vous
interveniez dans une affaire qui parfois
d'ailleurs est connu de la justice pour
savoir un certain nombre de choses et
que le garde des sceaux ne serait pas
informé de cela
pardonnez moi il est normal que le garde
des sceaux connaissent des affaires de
l'état
je me permets de vous dire monsieur le
nier ensuite d'ailleurs que les
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires
n'interviennent jamais dans le champ
denquête judiciaire et au parlement nous
y veillons mais je vous laisse
poursuivre vos réponses en ensuite vous
savez que je dois rédiger un rapport qui
vous ai transmis chaque année sur
l'application de la politique pénale
j'ai besoin de recevoir un certain
nombre d'informations
on ne peut pas écouter les textes
existent
si vous tes mais ce sont des
explications je vous demandais juste des
explications vous ne dites au fond du
besoin de remontée d'informations parce
que je suis responsable de la politique
pénale dessus et les informations sur
les affaires et devant israël contribue
à me permettre de forger la politique
pédales si c'est votre réponse je peux
l'entendre c'est aussi une de réponse et
les plus complexes mais cela me permet
de rédiger un rapport à destination du
parlement s'est passé pour nous et moi
j'estime pardonner c'est pour nous
évidemment j'en rends les armes
j'ai dit notamment et les adverbes ne
sont pas inutiles monsieur président
j'estime que le garde des sceaux peut
recevoir des informations sur des
affaires qui concernent le
fonctionnement de l'état
eh ben je vais vous dire je n'ai pas à
ce stade
voyez-vous reçu strictement aucune
information sur la situation de monsieur
darmanin je sais une chose et vous la
partagerez avec moi c'est qu'il est
présumé innocent nous sommes tous
d'accord là dessus je n'ai madame reçu
strictement aucune information sur sa
situation
allez monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole et vous seuls
vous m'avez vous n'avez monsieur le
sénateur demande et tout à l'heure si je
souhaitais faire évoluer les choses
vous avez évoqué cette affaire que je
connais bien l'ordre du jour l'un des
deux textes pourquoi pas laisser mois
seulement le temps d'en prendre
connaissance
je ne l'ait pas fait je n'ai pas eu le
temps de tout faire encore je découvre
un certain nombre de difficultés
problématique et je vous avoue
humblement que le temps qui m'a été
imparti ne me permet pas à cet instant
d'être au fait de l'ensemble des sujets
en particulier pardon de celui qui vous
préoccupe
pardon et ça n'est ni du désintérêt de
la désinvolture mais le temps et pense
qu'il est pense pas avoir perdu beaucoup
de temps pour le moment mais cette
question très précise je la regarderai
mes services ont entendu ce que vous
disiez vous aurez une réponse
prochainement
le secret de l'instruction la
présomption d'innocence bon vaste
préoccupation pour moi parce que d'abord
la dernière fois qu'on s'est préoccupé
de la présomption d'innocence
c'était dans le cadre d'une loi qui
remonte à à bientôt 20 ans madame
elisabeth guigou loi qui porte qui porte
son nom et depuis j'ai vu une
dégradation des choses au point que la
présomption d'innocence aujourd'hui est
reléguée au rang d'accessoires tout le
monde s'en moque
j'ai dit devant l'assemblée nationale je
crois il ya deux ou trois jours on
consacre des émissions à des affaires
qui sont en cours d'instruction
1h30 un homme se fait mais décide t on
entend des témoins à charge on a la
certitude qu'il est coupable
et vous avez en fin d'émission la petite
phrase magique
rappelons que monsieur bernard jeanjean
est présumé innocent ça ça peut plus
durer
ceci étant dit on et c'est une
expression que nous avons utilisé hier
sur la ligne de crête ce travail ne peut
être fait qu'avec les journalistes
évidemment parce que sinon nous
encourons le risque majeur des prêts
considérés comme d'insupportable
censeurs ils s'en prendraient à la
liberté de la presse
la presse a beaucoup de droit elle a
aussi des devoirs et je souhaite
faire un travail avec les journalistes
sur cette question parce que le constat
que l'on soit parlementaire ou avocat au
ministre depuis depuis quelques jours
c'est que la présomption d'innocence est
devenu totalement évanescente dans ce
pays
c'est insupportable le secret de
l'instruction alors là alors là n'en
parlons même pas n'en parlons même pas
je sais même plus si ça existe encore
avec cette difficulté que parfois ce qui
viole le secret de l'instruction
sans ce devant qui vous déposer une
plainte pour violation du secret de
l'instruction et ils ont quand même
grand peine à fournir toutes les
énergies pour s'auto incriminer donc là
aussi il faut qu'on regarde pas ce que
je souhaite raccourcir enquêtes
préliminaires dans sa durée ce que
préliminaires ça a un sens je souhaite
que cette enquête deviennent
contradictoire parce que les droits de
la défense
saint saëns et la justice ne peut être
rendue que dans le contradictoire et
puis je souhaite qu'on envisage comment
protéger l'honneur des hommes j'ai une
très très longue conversation avec
pierre baudis le fils de dominique
baudis et je crois qu'on a oublié
dominique baudis parce que les leçons la
matière ne sont jamais revenus et s'il
faut légiférer
eh ben on le fera parce qu'il faut
redéfinir les choses comme elles
méritent de l'être
on ne peut pas comme ça s'autoriser je
vois des choses assez stupéfiante
stupéfiante
j'avais assisté jeu pour illustrer ce
propos il pour vous dire à quel point
nos préoccupe sur un plateau de
télévision j'avais entendu deux grands
journalistes un grand journal du soir
dire qu'il disposait de l'intégralité du
dossier d' enquêtes préliminaires dans
la sphère dit fillon alors que ni fillon
ni ses avocats de l'époque ne pouvait
procéduralement obtenir ces documents
c'est scandaleux alors quand j'ai dit
mais vous avez obtenu sa dudu de qui
aurait dit secret des sources a secret
des sources d'accord mais alors du pnr
ah non non non alors moi j'ai suggéré
que la femme de ménage avait piqué le
dossier qu'elle
l'avis remis aux journalistes non il
faut qu'on travaille là-dessus vraiment
très très sérieusement
[Applaudissements]
le non non non non non non non mais ne
voyait pas du tout dans mon nom dans ma
fébrilité que votre question non mais je
vous ai dit en réalité déjà dans le
discours ce que je comptais faire là
dessus ma position
monsieur le sénateur elle est
extrêmement clair je suis pour une
séparation nette du siège et du parquet
une formule que j'ai très souvent
utilisé formule du président coo jarre
qui préside la cour d'assises de paris
qui lisait c'est quand même le seul
sport où l'un des arbitres portent le
même maillot qu'un des joueurs
j'indique d'ailleurs que dans la
magistrature on est plus sur une
position univoque là dessus il ya un
certain nombre de magistrats qui
souhaitent la séparation du siège et du
parquet moi c'est mon souhait pour un
tas de raisons je n'ai sans doute pas le
temps de les développer ici mais nous
nous reverrons je ne pourrais pas le
faire parce que je mange mon chapeau
mais le temps qui m'est imparti
m'interdit de 2,2 m 7
cette modification essentielle à mes
yeux en chantier oui alors oui oui oui
oui oui oui je jeu avec an des jeux non
sur la nuque alors je voudrais terminer
ce que ce que ce ce qui me semble
réformes structurelles essentielles que
je ne pourrais pas menée à son terme
non pas que je n'en ai pas envie mais ce
sont des rêves ou des utopies que le
calendrier me contraint à mettre de côté
mais oui mais vous m'avez posé des
questions sur le reste je vous réponds
sur l'os je voulais aussi évidemment
envisager l'école nationale de la
magistrature et envisager une école de
formation commune narrer ce sont des
choses importantes
je pourrais pas en revanche sur l'
ordonnance de 58
les magistrats et particulièrement ceux
du parquet attentes ces prêts forme et
il s'agit d'inscrire de graver dans le
marbre de la constitution
une pratique que ce pouvoir a toujours
respecté
voilà donc la réponse est oui vous nous
annoncer aujourd'hui que le président de
la république va convoquer le congrès
pour faire adopter définitive
man cette révision de la constitution
qui avait été voté en termes identiques
par les deux chambres
c'est ce qu'il a dit 7
c'est un scoop je vous remercie
alors l'expérimentation là aussi là
aussi là aussi non non attendez je le
cours d'assises ça mérite ça mérite une
seule une commission des lois pardonnez
moi et et qu'on en discute et qu'on en
discute complètement mais il ya des
expérimentations qui sont en cours
monsieur le sénateur il ya un stock à
résorber
non mais j'ai compris j'ai compris où
j'ai compris set j'ai compris je sais je
sais compter j'ai compris je vous donne
ma position je vous dis que c'est pour
moi la chronique d'une mort annoncée de
la cour d'assises
je ne veux pas qu'on prenne son show ce
chemin en est d'ailleurs procéder par
étapes d'abord on a réduit le nombre de
jurés ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui une
décision de condamnation n'est plus
prise à l'unanimité du jury populaire
ce n'est donc plus une juridiction
populaire au sens on pouvait l'entendre
autrefois
moi j'aime cette juridiction pour d'état
présente une bouffée d'oxygène dans le
corporatisme des juges je l' ai déjà dit
et c'est aussi on se souvient tout
simplement que la justice est rendue au
nom du peuple français et on est en
train d'exclure le peuple français du
fonctionnement de sa justice ça un autre
mérite c'est que les français qui sont
jurés qui sont amenés à rendre la
justice savent enfin comment fonctionne
la justice parce que entre la justice
qu'on rend au café du commerce et la
justice que l'on rend quand on a entre
ses mains le sort d'un homme
on appréhende la justice de façon
différente moi je ne veux pas laisser
mourir la cour d'assises je ferai tout
pour qu'elle ne meure pas je trouve que
c'est un jeu une juridiction qui marche
bien
les expérimentations sont en cours que
se poursuivre on en tirera les
conclusions mais il y aura toujours de
quoi dire ne fût-ce que sur le terrain
démocratique que cette institution doit
être maintenu
mais monsieur le ministre
est ce que la réforme de la justice des
mineurs va faire l'objet prochainement
d'une saisine du parlement voilà la
question
oui la réponse est oui oui mon cher
collègue bon là je pense maintenant
passé ne pouvons maintenant passer à la
suite des questions de vous signale
qu'il nous reste 24 minutes
vous êtes 10 à avoir demandé à poser une
question au ministre si chacun d'entre
vous accepte de poser sa question d'une
minute sans faire trop de commentaires
le ministre a le temps de vous répondre
alors je donne la parole à monsieur fera
sa fête sur le microsite président
monsieur le ministre
j'aborderai un sujet qui est celui de la
loi via et des contenus illicites
mon premier point je vais aller droit au
but c'est le bilan qu'on peut tirer de
la censure plutôt sévère qu'a fait le
conseil constitutionnel la loi via et la
question c'est quel bilan et après le
deuxième c'est le débat qui a eu lieu
tout récemment auquel le premier
ministre et vous même avait pris parti
dans
ce débat c'est celui sur l'anonymisation
mais que terme que je préfère plutôt la
pseudonyme isation des sur internet
l'anonymisation je pense que si on
l'interdît c'est à dire interdire
l'anonymat sur internet on risque
surtout de porter préjudice aux lanceurs
d'alertés surtout victime est le
pseudonyme à terme que je préfère est
donc sur lequel j'aimerais avoir votre
avis et quels moyens pour lever plus
facilement le pseudonyme a été surtout
identifié dans ce cas là les auteurs de
cette haine sur internet et j'ai terminé
dans la suite ce sera pour les suivants
puisque je refais une minute 15 monsieur
le président monsieur du rhin merci
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux jacques toubon avant de
quitter son poste insisté sur la
protection accordée aux lanceurs d'alert
votre prédécesseur madame belloubet
déclarait les whistleblowers sont l'un
des défis les plus importants de nos
démocraties un délit de transparence et
de justice
l'union européenne a adopté une
directive en novembre 2019 sur ce sujet
central et nous savons tous ce que les
lanceurs d'alert apporte à nos
démocraties sur la santé publique sur
l'environnement ou sur l'évasion fiscale
alors je vous ai lu le garde des sceaux
vous avez défendu un lanceur d'alert
célèbre vous avez aussi des propos plus
dur sur les lanceurs d'alerté maintenant
que vous êtes garde des sceaux est en
charge de ce dossier
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
votre vision des lanceurs d'alert de la
protection à leur apporter
et la manière dont vous envisagez
surtout transposer la directive
européenne que j'ai évoqués
merci chers collègues madame françoise
gatel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ma question porte
sur les maires qui sont trop souvent les
oubliés de la justice depuis quelques
temps on constate dans tout le
territoire français
une augmentation des incivilités voir
une augmentation des agressions parfois
très graves à l'égard des mères or très
souvent les maires qu'ils sont
dépositaires d'une autorité comptable
devant leur population de ce qui se
passe sont juste oublié dans le circuit
d'information la loi engagement et
proximité que nous avons voté ici en
décembre dernier impose que le maire
soit systématiquement informé non à sa
demande mais systématiquement informé
par le procureur de la république des
suites judiciaires qui sont donnés à ces
signalements ainsi qu'aux infractions
qui cause un trouble à l'ordre public
sur le territoire de sa commune
c'est un sujet extrêmement important
pour tous les élus dont beaucoup sont
nouveau aujourd'hui
donc monsieur le ministre quel retour
pouvez vous nous faire sur ce dispositif
et sur sa mise en application jour merci
chapiteau merci monsieur
non monsieur garde des sceaux s'agissant
de la justice des mineurs
soyez précis dans votre réponse si vous
le permettez le code la justice des
mineurs fait l'objet d'une ordonnance
qui était censée entrer en vigueur en
octobre prochain son entrée en vigueur a
été reportée est ce que pour vous il est
remis en cause et vous ferez un nouveau
texte
ou est-ce que vous reprendrez cette
ordonnance et on demanderait
l'homologation la question est très
précise mais aussi roanne en mars
en mars 2010 est la chancellerie publié
un avant projet de loi de réforme de la
responsabilité civile
ce texte faisait l'unanimité il a
travaillé pendant dix ans par les
spécialistes il est attendu
nous avons fait un rapport nous pensons
que ce texte pourrait sortir
or je sais que ce n'était pas dans les
préoccupations de votre prédécesseur
ce serait utile qu'ils puissent sortir
dans les 600 jours qui vous reste merci
merci chers collègues et madame marie
mercier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre un de vos premiers déplacements
a été pour le centre éducatif fermé
d'epinay sur seine dans le cadre d'une
mission ici au sénat nous avions visité
le centre
pourtant j'ai enlevé mon masque pour
vous parler un de vos je reprends un de
vos déplacements a été pour le centre
éducatif fermé d'epinay-sur-seine ici au
sénat nous avons fait une mission sur
les mineurs et nous étions allés au
centre de savigny-sur-orge avec un
directeur extraordinaire un personnel
motivé un projet éducatif solide et
malgré cela des résultats un peu
décevants et le directeur nous avait dit
vous savez ces jeunes ils sont
abandonnés seuls quelques mamans
viennent les voir mais pas de papa donc
quand les jeunes en arrive là c'est un
vrai échec de l'éducation à vrai échec
de l'accompagnement à la parentalité
aussi je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre si vous pensez vous aussi à la
réelle efficacité des centres éducatifs
fermés pensez vous qu'il faille en
construire de nouveaux sachant que dans
celui que vous avez visité il y à un
défaut de recrutement du personnel et
que vraiment la solution allait aussi
dans la formation du personnel qui
accompagnent ces jeunes
merci cher collègue monsieur thani
mohamed soilihi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux où vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la proximité de la
justice or ça fait dix ans que le
justiciable maoré est éloigné de son
juge d'appel puisque il y a dix ans
était créé la chambre d'appel détacher
de mayotte
rattaché à la cour d'appel de saint
denis
cette question est cruciale surtout à
l'aune de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 30 avril 2020 qui a
donné à l'état jusqu'au 31 octobre pour
arrêter le système de visioconférence
pour les justiciables au sein de
justiciables jugé dans la chambre de
l'instruction et des solutions doivent
être être trouvé or pour mayotte
la chambre de l'instruction se trouve à
la réunion il ne s'agit pas d'un caprice
c'est une question centrale
parce que voilà une situation où le
parquet général
le procureur général chargé de la
politique pénale et bien se trouve à à
2000 km à 2000 kilomètres défilent donc
comment peut-il décider efficacement de
la politique pénale à mayotte s'il n'en
connais pas la réalité
cette question est ancienne je l'avais
soumise à votre prédécesseur christiane
taubira je pensais que comme l avait
milité pour que la garde des sceaux
comprends très bien votre question je
lègue la chambre détachée de la guyane
vis-à-vis de la martinique s'arrête je
préfère qu'elle allait se saisir de
cette question et bien à caen il a
regardé à vous répondre mais c'est le
garde des sceaux a quand même si la cour
d'appel de plein exercice de mayotte
messieurs françois noël buffet monsieur
le ministre vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure que le temps de l'enquêté
préliminaire était beaucoup trop long
nous pouvons partager évidemment cette
analyse
cela veut-il dire monsieur le ministre
que le juge d'instruction va retrouver
son rôle et que alors que depuis
quelques années il semblait que son
destin en tous les cas la fonction
devenait funeste peut être entendez-vous
lui redonner le rôle qui lui appartient
madame benbassa
monsieur le ministre dès votre entrée en
force en fonction vous avez visité la
prison de fresnes et que comptez-vous
faire dans les 600 jours qui vous l'est
pour améliorer les conditions de
détention dans les lieux de privation de
liberté
je vais vous poser une seconde question
basique et vous avez également dès votre
arrivée visiter le tribunal de bobigny
que comptez-vous faire également pour
désencombrer les tribunaux et accélérer
le traitement des dossiers
merci certains tribunaux sont dans un
tel état vétuste et copieux de les
appeler tribunaux judiciaires on devrait
les appeler cour des miracles
et encore ça supposerait que les
justiciables soient satisfaits des
décisions qui sont rendus mais madame
d'euromédis merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux
pendant sa campagne électorale le
président de la république avait ici
initialement envisagé la construction de
quinze mille nouvelles places de prison
l'objectif a ensuite été révisé à la
baisse cette ville au cours du
quinquennat puis 8000 au cours du
quinquennat suivant pensez vous que
l'objectif de livrer 7000 nouvelles
places d'ici à 2022 puissent être tenus
outre la construction de nouvelles
places le programme immobilier de
l'administration pénitentiaire
permettra-t-il aussi d'améliorer les
conditions de détention en rénovant les
établissements vétustes
merci chers collègues et enfin la
dernière question est celle du président
caennais ram à droite
l'asp nos listes à votre droite
géographique monsieur trognon monsieur
le gala bien interprété autrement chers
collègues
non rassurez-vous je lis dans vos
pensées monsieur le président ministre
monsieur le ministre je garde des sceaux
vous allez être privée de liberté
pendant 20 mois minimum ou maximum
on verra bien quelle sera la suite donc
une question d'ordre général quelles
sont vraiment les deux ou trois
priorités qui sont les vôtres pendant ce
temps qui vous est compté et qui
permettra de redonner de l'espoir la
justice mais aussi aux justiciables
premièrement deuxièmement vous avez un
propos à l'égard de la haute autorité la
transparence la vie publique que nous
connaissons bien ici en tant que
parlementaires à l'occasion d'une
affaire concernant une ministre d'un
ancien gouvernement aux pratiques l'air
d'un quinquennat précédent il a eu aussi
quelques unes
à l'époque vous aviez vous joueriez
évoqué donc la haute autorité comme
étant un truc je répète un truc que une
espèce de truc populiste et ce propos a
été dénoncée disons le par le nouveau
président didier migaud et qu'il a
considéré comme un temps infamant donc
que pensez vous de cette haute autorité
que nous estimons nous comme étant un
plus pour la transparence dans la vie
publique et politique dans notre pays
eh bien monsieur le ministre vous
disposez d'une vingtaine de minutes pour
répondre alors la première question m'a
été posée par monsieur le sénateur
christophe-andré frassin
la question des réseaux sociaux et de
l'anonymat est une question infiniment
complexe à la fois les réseaux sociaux
c'est l'outil idéal d'une démocratie
participative et en même temps c'est
devenu une poubelle à ciel ouvert dans
certains cas alors ça protège
effectivement certains mais ça détruit
aussi de mon point de vue le tissu
social
moi je suis poursuivi par guacamole 425
et c'est insupportable
je dis que celui qui ne signent pas ne
devrait pas pouvoir s'exprimer quand son
propos quand son propos monsieur le
sénateur est injures antisémitisme
racisme homophobie sexisme
comment agir alors c'est toute la
difficulté
j'ai posé la question avec beaucoup de
d'humilité beaucoup de modestie parce
que j'ai pas la réponse
est-ce que technologiquement c'est
possible ou alors est ce que ce sont les
diffuseurs qu'il faut aller attaquer
mais c'est une vraie question
je n'aurais question jeu je pense que on
vit une époque un peu folle d'hyper
moralisation qui nous qui nous contraint
teint forme de manichéisme
il faut être pour ou contre c'est blanc
ou noir les uns deviennent les censeurs
des autres cette époque devient folle et
le ciment de notre nation c'est ce qui
nous unit pas ce qui nous distingue
en tous les cas pas en ces termes là et
moi je veux pouvoir argumenter je
préfère débattre que me battre et ses
réseaux sociaux
sous cette forme-là m'exaspère alors je
conçois que parfois l'anonymat peut
protéger bien sûr mais la plupart du
temps reconnaissant que et l'autre
inconvénient parlé tout à l'heure de
présomption d'innocence c'est que la
presse traditionnelle et dans la
surenchère des réseaux sociaux d'une
certaine façon est donc c'est le buzz
et c'est ce qu'on appelle chez les
journalistes pensaient que je voudrais
travailler avec eux le put à cliquer
faut faire de la mousse
parce que sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt de
les voir le journal il vaut mieux que
c'est plus simple pour la jeunesse
d'aller voir les réseaux sociaux donc
tout ça il faut que l'on y réfléchisse
parce que
je pense que ça peut faire trembler la
démocratie - il ya aussi une forme de
totalitarisme de la pensée qui nous
envahit qui nous interdit de réfléchir
qui nous interdit de faire un certain
nombre de choses qui nous contraint et
dans notre langue et dans nos choix
artistiques et tous à la haute assemblée
ne peut pas être insensible à ça j'ai
dit que je serais le garde des sceaux de
la liberté c'est vrai ça c'est une
question qui me préoccupe beaucoup
je voudrais d'abord voir comment comment
techniquement on peut te abordé la chose
avant avant d'y apporter une une réponse
claire nette et est plutôt précise les
lanceurs d'alert alors les lanceurs
d'alerté vous avez évoqué le fait tout à
l'heure que je j'ai défendu julian
assange
il ya d'abord il faut définir ce qu'est
le lanceur d'alerté parce que je les dis
à l'époque
non mais je sais mais je sais mais je
reprends ça parce que je l'entends du
madame la sénatrice n'a évoqué tout à
l'heure il faut définir qui l'on protège
et qui au fond est un délateur lanceur
d' alerte
est-ce que c'est là n'oublie semant des
délateurs ou est ce que c'est quelque
chose de différent
julien assange je les dis hein à
l'époque je je je peux m'exprimer très
librement là dessus il était à la fois
et il a apporté à notre pays un certain
nombre d'informations dont nous pouvions
avoir besoin en même temps parfois il
est allé sur le terrain de la vie privée
je ne les ai pas suivi sur ce terrain
voilà un premier distinguo à porter et
puis je vous dire qu'il est évidemment
nécessaire d'adopter notre d'adapter
notre droit à la directive le lanceur
d'alert ça n'implique pas de tout
changer mais des adaptations et une
consultation sera fait sur la question
on a ensuite évoqué les maires qui sont
agressés et comment
je demanderai aux procureurs d'appliquer
le nouveau texte je ferai très
prochainement
j'ai souri quand vous posiez la question
parce que c'est au fond pouvez vous nous
préciser quels nouveaux textes vous leur
demanderez d'appliquer monsieur le
président de la commission un texte
nouveau a été est entré en vigueur il
faut l'appliquer
je ne vais pas je n'ai pas son numéro je
n'ai pas sa date vous l'avez peut-être
en mémoire - non c'est parce que je
réponds je réponds la question qui m'est
posée
oui sur l'information du procureur au
maire assé l'instruction oui de votre
prédécesseur je comprends oui c'est
d'une instruction qui vise à mobiliser
les parquets ce la défense des mères
quand ils subissent des agressions et
des incivilités essais et c'est aussi
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière une
remontée d'informations et c'est très
important savoir la suite au travail
ce texte reçoivent une application bien
sûr et quand je ferai la circulaire
idoine j'indiquerai naturellement tout
ce qui permettra d'identifier ce texte
monsieur le président mais la même
mémoire est la vôtre d'ailleurs sont sur
ce point très précis peut-être un peu
défaillante et c'est normal il ya 15 à
il ya une loi grave la réversibilité
alors à la mer mais il ya une
instruction donnée par une instruction
donnée voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà pour être pour être précis vous
avez raison de exiger de moi que je le
sois eux vous met ensuite posé la
question monsieur le sénateur bio sur l'
ordonnance de jeanjean pas évidemment
poursuivre sur les textes et sur les
projets qui ont été présentés avant ma
nomination
ce sera notre base de travail quand
quand
oui oui c'est ce qui est prévu
non mais attendez monsieur monsieur le
sénateur moi j'arrive depuis dix jours
si vous pensez que j'ai eu le temps de
préparer un nouveau texte
vous me prêtez des pouvoirs qui ne sont
pas les miens et une compétence qui
n'est pas la mienne je pense que à
défaut à défaut madame pardonnez moi je
voudrais pas monsieur le sénateur à
défaut d'obtenir d'obtenir votre
adhésion j'aimerais au moins un peu
votre attentisme voilà ce qui est prévu
c'est que l' ordonnance soit présenté et
s'agissant de 2 et s'agissant et
s'agissant et ça non mais moi je sais
vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues je laissais répondre le
ministre sans l'année rencontre parce
que il y a beaucoup de questions
auxquelles il doit encore répondre
laisser leur aide sont s'agissant de la
réforme de la responsabilité civile
un projet a été préparé par mon
administration
j'en prends connaissance et nous nous
reverrons prochainement pour savoir
comment on va faire les choses madame
madame la sénatrice les sf orgie j'ai vu
comme vous sans doute des choses
absolument incroyable et en particulier
y avait là des gamins qui sont nés en
prison
ils sont nés en prison j'ai pensé à la
formule d'assurance je m'accroche
désespérément tama mauvaise étoile
ouais et je dîne une seule chose à ce
stade quand ils sont là ils ne sont pas
en prison est déjà ça ça me paraît une
victoire je sais pas si on en sauve
beaucoup mais si on en sauve un sur dix
déjà on n'a pas fait ça pour rien je
reviendrai sur ces questions évidemment
quand je les aurai étudier plus en
profondeur mais je pense que tout ce qui
est alternatif à la prison c'est quelque
chose qui va dans le bon sens et
d'ailleurs
je crois qu'une question m'a été posée
en ce sens il ya deux façons de
maintenir le taux c'est une question qui
m'a été posée par deux les moins par
madame la sénatrice esther benbassa
benbassa pardonnez moi d'abord il ya le
bloc pen qui rentrent en application
vous savez que le coc vide
a permis que le taux de détention soit
historiquement bas puisque les
cambriolages par exemple il n'a pas eu
beaucoup puisque les gens étaient
confinés chez eux
bon que l'activité économique nous
l'espérons tous reprend malheureusement
l'activité des mines consiel reprend
aussi donc pour le moment je suis dans
une forme de comment dirais je suis dans
la tente de voir comment les chiffres
vont évoluer mais je vais demander au
parquet je peux pas faire grand chose je
n'ai aucun pouvoir sur les juges du
siège et si j'ose cette plaisanterie en
la matière en la matière seulement je le
regrette je trouve qu'on abuse de la
détention provisoire c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui qu'on le dit la loi
consacre déjà cette idée que la
détention provisoire est une exception
est en réalité on sait très bien que ça
devient souvent la règle est déjà dans
les travaux parlementaires
après l affaire d'outreau on avait
signalé stigmatiser l'idée que le
recours à la détention provisoire était
une espèce de mauvaises habitudes
culturelles m'entends ancré dans dans
l'esprit de notre institution dont il ya
deux façons
maintenant de maintenir ce chiffre au
niveau le plus bas et pour des tas de
raisons
c'est le bloc peine bien sûr et puis et
puis un certain nombre de de réquisition
qui pourront être prises par les
procureurs et puis peut-être aussi
pardonnez-moi élever un peu le débat sur
ces questions et réponses et ce qu'est
la prison parce que on a la chance
d'appartenir à ce merveilleux pays qui
est le pays des droits de l'homme et des
tas de gens ont écrit sur ce qu'est la
prison
elle a un triple but la prison c'est
évidemment de punir de mettre à l'écart
de la société à un homme une femme
dangereux et de réinsérer et on peut pas
envisager l'instant les deux autres or
la prison est galvaudé aujourd'hui et
dans certaines affaires où le critère de
dangerosité par exemple n'est pas là on
constate une inflation du recours à la
prison en termes de décisions rendues
par les tribunaux où les cours d'appel
et alors l'autre façon d'intervenir
c'est la détention provisoire
pour quelle raison dans notre pays on ne
parvient pas en dépit des efforts dépit
de tout ce qui a été écrit et là encore
ça transcende les clivages politiciens
on ne parvient pas à obtenir que
quelqu'un soit jugées libres
évidemment dans certains cas vous l'avez
bien compris et des cas où le problème
ne se pose pas en terme de dangerosité
de gravité des faits moi je les dis je
pas de baguette magique je veux pas de
matraque je ne serai pas le garde des
sceaux du laxisme mais je ne sais pas en
garder son ultra répressif évidemment
mais on pourrait réfléchir autrement eh
ben voilà quelques pistes la détention
provisoire réfléchir à la prison mais le
garde des sceaux quand un homme est jugé
n'était pas très efficace quand il était
avocat il est encore moins quand et les
ministres c'est pas lui qui prend la
décision mais on peut aussi d'ailleurs
obtenir l'intervention législative pour
mettre des seuils parce que si je ne
parviens pas à obtenir ce que je
souhaite évidemment on envisagera cette
solution elle a déjà été envisagée par
le passé devrait vous rappeler que à un
moment on peut pas incarcérer un homme
pour un vol 5 3 ans d'emprisonnement et
on a vu des pratiques judiciaires
insupportable qui contournait la volonté
du législateur en retenait des
circonstances aggravantes notamment la
bande organisée et on a vu fleurir des
vins blancs bande organisée avec un
maximum encouru supérieure à 3 ans et
comme ça on pouvait retourner vers nos
viennent nos vieilles habitudes nos
vieilles habitudes délétère et
réincarcéré de façon provisoire dont il
faut veiller à tout ça on a on a on a un
arsenal complet et moi j'entends que le
taux de détention ne redevienne pas
celui qui autorise la cour européenne à
nous condamner régulièrement pour les
conditions inhumaines et dégradantes de
nos prisons parce que voilà nous
interrompons cette audition d'eric
dupond-moretti car dans une dizaine de
minutes exactement comme ans les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ce rendez vous phare de la semaine
parlementaire lors duquel les sénateurs
ont pouvoir questionner interpeller le
gouvernement
en attendant alors que retenir de cette
audition d'eric dupond-moretti
1 le fait que le nouveau garde des
sceaux
insiste sur l'instauration d'une justice
de proximité pour lui il faut rétablir
le lien de confiance entre le citoyen et
la justice et pour cela le garde des
sceaux réclame l'accélération des délais
de la justice également noté qu'il a
insisté sur le combat du gouvernement
contre les violences faites aux femmes
après le texte adopté hier par le sénat
et qui est là d'ailleurs défendu dans
l'hémicycle le garde des sceaux qui est
critiquée par les associations
féministes depuis sa nomination
mais le temps fort le moment de tension
de cette audition c'est sans conteste ce
moment où eric dupond moretti a dû
répondre sur les remontées
d'informations que le gouvernement que
le garde des sceaux assure des affaires
individuelles
il répondait à une question de la
sénatrice socialiste marie-pierre de la
gontrie qui lui a demandé quel
dispositif était mis en place pour qu'il
n'ait aucune remontée concernant les
affaires dans lesquelles il a plaidé
comme avocat écoutez la réponse d'eric
dupond-moretti
je ne m'interdis aucune remontée
d'information sauf celles qui ont pu
conserver mon activité antérieure je
vous dirai ce que j'ai fait je
m'interdis en revanche et nous sommes
dans les clous des textes de donner
quelques directives que ce soit à qui
que ce soit c'est très clair ceci étant
dit vous le savez comme moi c'est le
lieu là aussi de tous les fantasmes et
de toutes les interprétations et
personne ne sera jamais convaincu ya un
grand principe de notre droit c'est que
la mauvaise foi ne se présume pas alors
s'agissant des affaires qui m'ont
concerné je n'aurais sur ces questions
là aucune remontée d'émanations eu
d'information aucune strictement aucune
voilà sur ce temps fort de cette
audition noter enfin qu'au niveau du
fonds eric dupond moretti a également
confirmé que le président de la
république convoquerait le congrès pour
réviser la constitution et faire en
sorte que la nomination des magistrats
du parquet face avec l'avis conforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
c'est un scoop à d'ailleurs réagi le
président de la commission des lois
philippe bas il faut dire que cette
révision constitutionnelle tant attendue
est de plus en plus hypothétique
on va passer tout de suite aux réactions
à cette audition salle des conférences
où arrivent bien les ministres vous le
voyez vous voyez notamment et bien la
nouvelle ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot qui se rend à salle des
conférences et alex temps
il ya une réaction sur cette audition
vous êtes avec le sénateur socialiste
jacques bigot avec le sénateur jacques
bigot est d'abord une réaction à ce
moment de tension durant l'audition
d'eric dupond moretti sur la remontée
d'informations qu'il pourrait avoir en
tant que ministre concernant des
affaires dans lesquelles il a plaidé en
tant qu'avocat qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de la réponse du ministre
lorsqu'elle n'est pas d'une clarté
absolue ce qui est important il est
logique que le ministre la justice garde
des sceaux est une information puisqu'il
doit donner le sens de la politique
pénale sur ce qui se passe globalement
et quelles sont les pages les pratiques
des départs quai mais toute information
concernant des affaires personnelles ne
devrait pas remonter au garde des sceaux
c'est important de le faire est d'autant
plus que eric dupond moretti a été
avocat il ya le secret professionnel il
ne doit faire la liste des gens qui ont
été ses clients ce qu'il a défendu
publiquement ça c'est connu mais il ya
aussi des gens qui sont venus le
consulter souvent c etc
donc il faut clairement empêché et c'est
vrai pour lui mais pour tous garde des
sceaux qu'il y ait de remontée
d'informations personnelles alors durant
cette audition le nouveau ministre de la
justice a défendu l'idée d'une justice
de proximité d'une proximité de la
justice
est ce que vous croyez qu'il va mener à
bien ce chantier alors on n'est pas très
clair sur la notion de proximité de la
justice ce qui peut paraître intéressant
c'est de dire
les juges devraient aller se déplacer
dans les chambres de proximité
aujourd'hui on a un tribunal judiciaire
parfois deux par département parfois un
seul devra département et puis des lieux
de justice qui étaient des anciens
tribunaux d'instance qui sont des
chambres détachées pourquoi est-ce qu
effectivement les juges aux affaires
familiales les juges des enfants
n'iraient pas dans ces juridictions la
procéder à leur audience
ça me paraît tout à fait possible moi je
l'avais suggéré donc oui je suis
intéressé à cette justice de proximité
pour le reste s'agissant des uns fait si
d'incivilité autres on est sur un autre
une autre thématique c'est pas le et
puis il faut pas oublier que le garde
des sceaux a plein de bonnes intentions
la vraie question c'est quelle sera les
moyens dont il disposerait en six ans
jour pour faire bouger la justice le
budget de la justice sera notre attente
est la question des moyens la justice le
garde des sceaux n'y a pas vraiment
répondu merci beaucoup
jacques bigot d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandrins dans quelques
minutes maintenant vont commencer les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vous le voyez sur cette image il y a du
monde qui arrive salle des conférences
parmi les thèmes importants alors de
cette séance est bien noté qu'il y aura
une interpellation du gouvernement par
la droite sénatoriale avec une question
de françois noël buffet à eric
dupond-moretti justement sur et de la
réponse pénale aux actes de violence
alors qu'il ya une multiplication des
actes de violence des actes d'incivilité
mais aussi il y en a un certain nombre
de faits divers et de crimes extrêmement
graves ces derniers jours noté que l'on
voit également arriver bien gérard
larcher le président du sénat qui va
être bien pouvoir dans quelques minutes
présidé cette dernière séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
autre thème important est bien la
question de la gratuité des masques
alors que depuis lundi les masques sont
obligatoires dans les lieux publics clos
hier est bien le président de la
république emmanuel macron a exclu la
gratuité des masques pour tous voilà qui
fait réagir notamment et bien le groupe
communiste et d'ailleurs alexandre vous
êtes avec la sénatrice communiste du val
de marne laurence cohen
mais oui laurence queen est ce qu est-ce
que c'est au contribuable de payer des
masques gratuits pour tous
emmanuel macron le président la
république pense que non égoutter et
moins ce que je pense surtout avec
l'ensemble de mon groupe le groupe
communistes républicains citoyens
écologistes c'est que les masses doivent
être pris à 100% par la sécurité sociale
donc ça ça serait une mue une mesure de
justice sociale d'égalité c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai déjà demandé dans
une question au gouvernement qu'il avait
refusé j'espère que ils ont médité
cette proposition est que ils vont
accepter cette prise en charge à 100%
pour toutes et tous par la sécurité
sociale
parce que nous sommes là dans une mesure
de protection de la santé et donc c'est
normal que signer cette prise en charge
mais alors est-ce que des personnes
aisées devrait avoir ce remboursement de
la sécurité sociale pour avoir pratiqué
la sécurité sociale est un système de
protection sociale pour tout le monde
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas mélanger
les genres
nous sommes dans un dans des dans un
produit qui est indispensable pour la
santé des françaises et des français
donc il faut que ça soit pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale et pour en avoir
les moyens il
pour arrêter de faire les exonérations
de cotisations sociales puisque en ce
moment même le gouvernement vide les
caisses de la sécurité sociale donc
c'est là la vraie problématique
et puis s'il ya besoin de mesures de
justice mais il faut rétablir l'impôt
sur la fortune là c'est une autre mesure
mais ne mélangeons pas les gens quand il
s'agit de dispositifs pour la santé
c'est pour tout le monde
la prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale très bien - votre programme
éclair merci beaucoup merci alexandre
également dans l'actualité le plan de
relance européen alors qu'un accord a
été trouvé hier au petit matin pour ce
plan de 750 milliards d'euros
la journée a été qualifié d'historique 1
par le président de la république
emmanuel macron alors que je le rappelle
ce plan faisait l'objet de négociations
extrêmement tendu un plan de relance
massif fondé pour la première fois sur
un endettement commun face à la
récession sans précédent qui menace
l'europe et alexandrins pour commenter
et bien cette nouvelle actualité vous
êtes avec le président ait l'air de la
commission des affaires européennes ray
sénateur jean bizet a effectivement jean
bizet le président de la république
parle d'une victoire historique pour
l'europe avec ce plan de relance est cet
endettement commun skis emmanuel macron
n'en fait pas un peu trop dans ce
service après vente de ce plan de
relance
disons qu l'accord obtenu hier à une
heure je dirais très matinal est quand
même un accord exceptionnel
imaginons se retrouver ya quelques mois
personne ne pouvait penser qu'on aurait
et je dirais un style et une dose de
fédéralisme budgétaire dans le
fonctionnement de l'union il a fallu une
pandémie mondiale
pour démontrer la fragilité de l'union
européenne avec un marché unique est le
premier marché économique mondiale est
une monnaie unique mais précisément des
discordances entre les économies des
différents états membres
il fallait donc un début de budget
commun un endettement commun en ce sens
je dirais cet accord et amman un accord
historique
alors la question qui se pose après
l'émotion de la victoire et de l'annoncé
d'hier c'est comment on va financer ce
plan est ce que vous êtes vraiment sûr
qu'au final ce ne sont pas les
contribuables français qui vont payer
c'est on ne voudrait pas que ce soient
les contribuables
je dirais européen qui paye il est bien
évident que ça nous oblige cet accord
nous oblige nous oblige à être courageux
politiquement inventif on sait le faire
en règle générale en europe en france en
particulier
en clair ça suppose que nous trouvions
ce qu'on appelle des ressources propres
et en dehors de la taxe sur les
plastiques usagés qui est une taxe qui
devrait rapporter 3 milliards d'euros
mais qui a vocation à s'étendre en
fonction du caractère vertueux du
comportement de nos concitoyens moi
j'estime qu'il y à d'autres pistes et
d'autres pistes que celles également
toujours de la taxation de l'innovation
autre jeu soit pour les gars femme vous
trouvez un module vingt dix pour
effectivement faire en sorte que ces
grandes entreprises n'échappe pas comme
les autres entreprises le font à une
participation financière
moi je pense si vous voulez à la lutte
contre la fraude sur la tva et la fraude
sur les tv au niveau européen c'est 60
70 milliards et bien une quote-part sûr
je dirais cette mise en oeuvre serait
bénéfique pour amorcer les ressources
propres donc une taxe sur l'activité des
géants du numérique en europe vous
n'êtes pas très favorable écoutez chacun
connaît la position de l' ocde en la
matière ça suppose également un vote à
l'unanimité
c'est pas facile ce n'est pas facile il
faut trouver le juste équilibre entre
faire payer ces grandes entreprises
je dirais qu'ils sont presque virtuel au
niveau de la taxation sans casser
l'innovation sens mettent en
porte-à-faux avec les études avec les
états unis
quoique quoique
l'extra territorialité des lois
américaines nous prouve que nous devons
nous affirmer affirmer la puissance de
l'europe
moi je pense plutôt à d'autres
alternatives voilà une taxe carbone aux
frontières européennes restent un
discours lundi cependant indispensable
pour moraliser entre guillemets certains
rapports et pour éviter les fuites de
carbone très bien ça ne va pas freiner
un peu nos importations
peut-être un peu mais faut moraliser
également tout cela très bien merci
beaucoup jean bizet d'avoir répondu à
mes questions et dans quelques instants
la séance des questions d'actualité et
du sénat au gouvernement va commencer
c'est tout de suite la séance est
ouverte